est-ce que vous avez des difficultés
pour remplir votre déclaration mais
assez agitée c'est compliqué chaque
année c'est le même refrain pour
certains français remplir sa déclaration
d'impôts c'est une corvée pour d'autres
c'est même une phobie administrative qui
viennent pas là tatras rires je traîne
toujours ses phobies la télévision s'y
intéresse depuis les années 60
parfois sur un ton sérieux ou au
contraire avec une touche d'humour à
l'image de l'acteur jean lefebvre
complètement perdu dans ses papiers
c'était en 1970 n'hésitant si longtemps
à l'avancé vos impôts si j'y pense
longtemps la mention monsieur tous les
jours c'est pas difficile j'en rêve la
nuit je vois des gars comme ça comme ça
toute la nuit ce qui vaut à l'avance
c'est préférable
sinon on s'expose à des déconvenues
exemple en 1991 les déclarations
tardives faisait déborder la boîte aux
lettres d'un centre des impôts à paris
compétent si on refuse mais un faux mais
je garderai pour moi 1996 toujours à la
poste du louvre à paris
le constat reste le même les français
les impôts ça fait deux et pourquoi vous
êtes arrivé si tard en retard peut dire
parce que je suis toujours en retard à
l'époque pas de déclaration sur internet
mais seulement sur papier les
contraintes sont plus nombreuses il faut
une enveloppe se déplacer à la poste
parfois même sortir la calculette et ça
ça demande un effort parce que
faso c'est trop compliqué c'est trop
compliqué calcul est calculé il ya
d'autres choses à faire en agit que de
calculer aujourd'hui la déclaration
d'impôt s'est simplifié internet
remplissage automatique
pourtant les retardataires existe
toujours et s'exposent à des sanctions
la majoration peut aller jusqu'à 10% de
l'impôt dû
[Musique]